hey guys I'm Lucy and welcome to reality
check now there's not really been that
much going on in the news lately well as
opposed there was that one thing Batman
Arkham Knight grappled onto PC with much
fanfare
sadly the wrong kind widespread
complaints of bugs freezing audio
glitches and a framerate capped at 30
led to publish a Warner Brothers quickly
pulling the game from sale
however Warner Brothers is not exactly
the only culprit here PC players are all
too familiar with borked versions of
otherwise acclaimed video games
take for instance Resident Evil force
constant crashing or the potato quality
assets of enslaved Odyssey to the West
who could forget the broken save files
of watch dogs or the capped 720 output
and wonky controls of the notoriously
easy Dark Souls the list goes on and on
and sadly on it's not a new problem but
it's one that doesn't look like it's
going away anytime soon
either but pcs got the beefier hardware
so surely it should be the superior
platform how come with some games that's
not the case well let me try and explain
well here's a first generation
PlayStation 4 console and here's another
first generation PlayStation 4 console
now the hardware inside both of these
machines is identical they both have the
same eight core AMD CPU they both have
eight gigabytes of RAM and they both
have the same 1.8 for teraflop AMD GPU
not much like in previous console
generations there's your first model and
then a slimmer more cost-effective model
coming along a bit later so while the
hardware goes through many makeovers
it's inside to remain relatively the
same anyway once you buy this first
generation console that's it
you might upgrade the storage and
download some updates well okay you'll
be downloading a lot of updates but
you've got the same hardware for the
consoles whole lifecycle which for the
Xbox one and PlayStation 4 is projected
to be around 10 years so when developers
are making a game for console they know
exactly what they're working with they
know the console CP
you GPU and memory limitations and know
how hard they can push their code to
make it work within them while home
consoles may be seen as being limited by
though fixed Hardware with PC that's not
the case you can within reason and at
greater expense swap things out if you
want to for example I have a PC with RAM
GPU and a processor that's one possible
combination of parts what if I switch
out my GPU my PC may remain at the same
specs but my GPU is made by different
manufacturer all right now what happens
if I change my processor that's another
combination of parts and what if this
time the spec of the whole machine
changes there's basically an
unfathomable number of combinations so
while you may have a sweet customized
and unique rig think about it what is
the likelihood that someone else is
gonna have that exact same hardware
configuration unfortunately the sheer
number of unique PC build is a big pain
in the optimizable but for developers I
mean your PC is still sweet though the
PC landscape is not a consistent testing
environment there are so many variables
if a developer makes a build of a game
that works on one PC configuration it
might not work on another
incompatibilities can be addressed as
they arise with specific driver updates
but as is the case with many recent
games if the game is compromised at its
core more drastic measures may be
required and this is an incredibly
arduous and time-consuming process
someone needs to figure out all the
possible combinations uncover issues and
then someone else needs to go in and fix
them all debugging takes a lot of
manpower and a lot of time and if
there's one thing that developers never
ever have enough of its time so how can
games be released on PC when they're
full of issues well when you release a
game on console you have to pass Sony
Microsoft or Nintendo's internal
certification process to make sure that
it's fit for release on PC however there
is no governing body carrying out
quality checks like this but what about
QA you cry well it's a common assumption
that when a buggy game gets released
it's because QA missed something this
isn't usually true more often than not
QA knows everything wrong with the game
but it's
to devs to decide whether to fix each
problem and as I mentioned with the
sheer number of possible PC builds out
there there's a lot of bugs to uncover
and a lot of bugs to fix but surely it's
in the publishers best interest to ship
the best possible vote of their game
well yes but also know this is the money
bit when publishers prepared to release
the game everything they do is driven
towards one single release date they
will allocate all marketing PR events
and advertising spend on to that one
crucial release date however is any
version ships a few months later it will
be released without the buzz without the
fanfare without the targeted advertising
spent and without the increased public
awareness and in an industry that's
trying to adjust to massively rising
production costs delaying a PC release
doesn't seem cost-effective especially
when you take into account the return on
investment of PC ports they're very
expensive due to all the debugging and
general extra work involved they also
release into a market that's easy to
steal from the Entertainment Software
Association estimated that the games
industry lost three billion dollars to
piracy in 2007 alone and a couple of
years ago Ubisoft head Yves Gill mo
while presumably taking a break from not
announcing Beyond Good and Evil 2
claimed that the company suffered a 90%
piracy rate on its PC titles now these
figures are most likely an
over-exaggeration
he'll moe himself even paired his figure
down a little bit but there's no denying
that piracy is a problem on PC a 2013
study that tracked games on a torrent
client over a three-month period found
around twelve point six million unique
users sharing illegal copies of around
200 games while the titles varied in age
from new releases to modern classics but
still hundreds of millions of dollars
worth of potential revenue being taken
out of a publisher and developers
pockets which in turn means less of the
investment being returned so if you were
a publisher would you think it's worth
putting all of your money into a market
where piracy is so rife or will you just
release your game anyway and patch it
later once you've got money coming in
from sales now we're not saying it's
always this way take GTA 5 the PC
version launched a full year and a half
after the original console
as rock star put extra time and money
into optimizing it and even spend more
money adding in new features but very
few games are gonna make 1 billion
dollars in 3 days and even fewer are a
safer bet on PC as GTA 5 was hopefully
I've outlined my PC ports are such a
complex issue and why we hear horror
stories about the really bad ones when
you think about it it's all just one big
vicious circle if publishers aren't
gonna get their money back after porting
to the PC market they're not going to
invest their resources in it in the
future and if consumers aren't getting a
good enough product they may turn to
piracy and maybe that's where DRM fits
in but more on that another time that's
all I got for you this week hopefully
this episode encourages some discussion
either post it in the comments below or
let me know on Twitter I'm at Lucy James
games I'll see you next time
you